new at noon the cases of two local
athletes back in court first former las
vegas raider henry ruggs as you may
remember he is accused of driving more
than 150 miles an hour while drunk
crashing into another car and killing
that driver today ruggs's attorneys were
in court they say they now have metro
police body camera video from the scene
back in november ruggs faces four felony
charges next court date is set for march
also the case against former bishop
gorman basketball star and unlv recruit
zeon collins back in court although he
wasn't his attorneys were same as
mr ruggs's today the attorneys there say
they are still waiting for the nevada
supreme court to decide if they're going
to consider actually dropping criminal
charges against collins recently a grand
jury indicted him on a felony reckless
driving charge but it declined to move
forward on felony dui
grant the grand jury didn't believe
marijuana was a factor in that 2019
crash a 52 year old man was killed in
the collision collins attorneys are back
in court in april